e hicieron un comunicado conjunto a eeuu
y los tres países de la unión europea en
el que dicen que harán todo lo posible
para evitar que irán se haga con el arma
nuclear y toman nota dicen de las
provocaciones de la república islámica
ellos se refieren al enriquecimiento de
uranio de alta calidad que ha hecho irán
a también al hecho de que se haya
alejado de la agencia internacional de
la energía
atómica del hecho de que en junio
justamente haya suspendido los
acercamientos que tenía con las
potencias occidentales en vista de las
elecciones en ese país que finalmente
ganó un presidente ultraconservador y
dicen también las potencias occidentales
que irán no tienen ningún uso pacífico
para que el que necesita una cantidad de
energía de esa calidad por lo mismo
dicen ellos es urgente que tanto eeuu
recordemos que donald trump sacó al país
del acuerdo del año 2015 que eeuu y la
república islámica vuelvan a la mesa de
negociaciones lo antes posible así se
levantarán las sanciones dicen las
potencias y en esto cuentan con la
colaboración de rusia y de china que son
aliados recordemos de ira en américa y
el impuesto mínimo global ya está listo
sobre el papel
ya está listo sobre el papel es una de
las buenas noticias de este g-20 que ya
podemos dar por aprobada ya se había
aprobado un impuesto parecido recordemos
en octubre a comienzos de este mes en el
seno de la sede se trata de un impuesto
de un 15% a las multinacionales para que
en fin paguen sus impuestos en los
países donde tienen sus actividades
recordemos que hace 40 años se
estableció esta idea de que los países
proponían a las empresas multinacionales
impuestos muy muy bajos para atraerlos y
así obviamente tener impuestos en sus
países y crear empleos sin embargo en
vista de la crisis derivada de la crisis
sanitaria la crisis económica los países
han visto sin dinero en déficit y
necesitan recursos y de dónde van a
venir esos dineros justamente de esas
multinacionales como las gafas por
ejemplo entonces ahora van a tener que
pagar esos impuestos en los países donde
tienen las actividades es una manera
obviamente de redistribuir los ingresos
mundiales es una de las buenas noticias
y aprobada otra que está casi casi
segura es la con respecto también a la
crisis sanitaria que está el tema
justamente de hoy es la vacunación a
mediados del próximo año de un 70 por
ciento de la población mundial los
países desarrollados del g20 de la
población está casi en más de un 60%
vacunada no es el caso en los países
pobres donde apenas un 4,5 por ciento de
la población tiene una dosis de las
vacunas es una también de las medidas
que está casi segura asegura aprobada y
la otra es que eeuu está empujando para
crear un fondo en el banco mundial para
financiar las vacunas justamente y que
el mundo se encuentre más preparado para
hacer frente a una pandemia como la del
cohete 19